[Music]
let's go ahead and just uh
throw this piece of art high-end art at
y'all real quick just want you to enjoy
the art show
it's right here oh yeah i love this one
dude i bet i know what the name of this
piece is called what is it called
matchsticks
that's pretty good nah man it gets
better
there's an artist there's a 2.0 that
made that evolved this piece this is
actually considered a million dollar
painting wow really
[ __ ] that was recently vandalized oh no
after a quote-unquote board security
guard
drew
eyes so funny some say vandalized i say
enhanced
i say
i say dude imagine you're that you're
you're hired to protect this painting
and you go i'm gonna mess with this he
drew on it he just drew ours resounding
hype from what he did make it cost more
i think it should it should right i
think i'd pay more money i want to know
his mentality like what he was thinking
because he's like dude look at his
unfinished piece of [ __ ] is he dead
do some mafia fools own that piece of
art and they're like that guy's done
he's definitely fired you're the guy
that did the ice
[Laughter]
big fan give them props afterwards yeah
i mean like what's the security is the
garden like oh man didn't finish it yo i
got this
i went to fellas
college for art homie this uh this
security guard this is funny it was his
first day of work there first day
is he first day at work dude man he's
got to be like [ __ ] cuckoo yeah where
is this at how could he don't
is there a photo this guy comes he's
probably like hey how come no one's done
this i gotta i gotta jump on this
photo of the dude his eyes look exactly
like that
self-portrait
that's all his eyes are all small and
[ __ ] big ass that they're like this tiny
or is it the hiring person's fault
where they forgot to go through the
rules and go hey do not draw on anything
you could draw on anything
question of past experience a background
check you know have you ever drawn on
another painting that was not yours like
they didn't ask they failed
yeah he probably thought no one would
notice like have you vandalized anything
he's like no but i got a graffiti record
you know yeah it's probably one of those
why do they keep saying he's bored so
this was uh i don't know why becky
monsanto um the three figures painted uh
painting by anna leporskaya was defaced
at the yeltsin center located in the
city of ekiterenberg in the swedish
oblast region in west central russia you
could have just said you don't know
where it's from
you have to make [ __ ] up
i have been i haven't been to
yakitaranbury before though actually in
russia of course you have auntie lee
[ __ ] sex however i've been like three
or
why do you think they're all doing the
anthony lee
[Laughter]
russian he's probably like hello
[Laughter]
so this uh board a 60 year old security
guard allegedly drew eyes with a
ballpoint pen
on the faces of two of the three figures
in the painting during an exhibition
called the world as non-objectivity the
birth of a what's a 60 year old biggest
security guard
oh my god the unnamed guard was
reportedly from a private security
company and has since been fired yeah no
[ __ ] imagine
what's the big ideas they gotta move
them like catholic priests and [ __ ] they
gotta move yeah they gotta rotate them
he's touching all the paintings yeah
this [ __ ] gets fired but a
catholic priest just gets moved that's
crazy dude i know right they move into a
gallery where all the paintings have
eyes already he's like [ __ ] you can do
no damage here
starts drawing noses
mouths why didn't i think of that
he gets better at vandalizing over time
he strikes again
i'm surprised catholic priests somehow
made it into this conversation
because nothing beats that rotation man
that's a
it's like a fighter like you lose
and then like you want to maintain your
undefeatedness so like you move to a
different league beat a bunch of kids
yeah
so this is actually an old painting le
por skaia who was a student of russian
avant-garde artist kashmir malevich is
having their three figures painting from
1932 to 1934
worked on by experts in a bid to restore
it to its former glory i imagine the
experts are like hey you got to remove
these ball boy pins
good luck
like the extras like i don't understand
what's wrong
this is beautiful wow so someone's got
to get a [ __ ] eraser and just go into
it like this real slow
it's just white eyes the roll on
the one that's rolls
they gotta just do this
i know all right
saliva dude so they're really working on
removing the eyes they're working on it
and this part sounds really funny to me
so let's make let's make sense of the
math after the after the incident police
opened an investigation for vandalism
which comes with a uh
40 000
ruby rupe what do they have in
restaurants
rupees that's not right
that's right i just made that up guys i
don't know if it's rubles is it or 395
pounds fine and a one year correctional
labor sentence however the damage to the
painting has been estimated at two
thousand four hundred seventy pounds wow
well that's it two thousand four hundred
and seventy what about the emotional
damage to art critics technically the
artist the artist has already passed so
there's no uh emotional damage to them
what about who owns the painting though
that's true because that's like a
million dollar painting right
i'm surprised that that didn't like
make it like 500 000 and then they got a
refund everyone that bought tickets to
the gallery expecting to see they're
like oh you [ __ ] it up man
i would just take a photo of that and
make posters
and sell those like
if i was the perpetrator the vandalizer
you know enemy of the nft yeah yeah
dude i think it's just like so much more
of a talking point of art like i would
never dude it put that painting on the
map yeah i would not have this painting
as its original for any reason but the
idea of the story of a guy who was bored
drawing ballpoint pen eyes on it i'm
like that's [ __ ] art you got to make
it example the guy so people don't do it
to everything when you said it was ball
point uh pen it doesn't really it looks
like it matches the hair of the [ __ ]
uh i was confused
yeah like i was like you think it took
this guy like four hours or something
though you know what i mean it wasn't
perfect and even the amount the eyes are
spaced apart from the sides of the head
and the forehead it's pretty good so
what if somebody saw this outcome and
they decided to put mike tyson's face
tattoo on mona lisa that's kind of cool
you like that
it's modern or you make mona lisa cross
line a little bit
and then they change the the plaque to
say mona lisa
i'm curious about his mindset though
like you know the board security guard
like like if we put that that mindset in
other security guards like a as a strip
club like is a board security guard does
he get lap dances does he like grow up
the stripper you know he's so bored yeah
yeah like when they're bent over he
draws a happy face on them like he draws
eyes on the eyeless strippers what's the
context but also though if you're a
board security guard at a strip club
you know get a different job because i
feel like that's the best place to be a
security guard what like being a board
security guard is a good thing because
you're not [ __ ] doing anything that's
true does that mean you're yeah your
jobs there's no crime yeah it's pretty
chill yeah because a board security
guard at a grocery store just like takes
an apple and eats what if he's like a
[ __ ] rambo madman security guard and
just craving action and nothing was
happening
he's a rambo man man and i don't kill i
draw eyes
at a museum
just be glad that's all i
did his release is his art you know and
he probably was like a special forces he
murdered like 30 people in like one
month or whatever and then like this is
his break now his security guard and
they hired they didn't ask him any
background questions because they saw
him they saw his resume like oh this is
a perfect security guard little did they
know
that his release is his art that's his
real passion
and he's like finally at 60 years old i
can retire and pursue my passions right
when they see this they're gonna [ __ ]
blow their minds and he finishes their
eyes and he's like that's me right there
man they're hella scared to tell him
that it was a bad thing you're like you
you told him that he shouldn't have done
that
someone wanted to tell me something
because his dream is he matt damon he
good will hunting oh the painting you
know i'm gonna get discovered because if
you look at the placement the size of
the eyes everything's proportional he's
like i'm i'm a prodigy i'm a prodigious
artist in my 60s he's probably a closet
like aspiring artist
he's just embarrassed he don't want to
talk about it that's what it is i feel
bad for the guy now he now he can't get
old now he can't be an artist anywhere
because he's ostracized from the [ __ ]
community to make up for now he's going
to kill more people because he's got to
get it out of his now he's back to
killing we [ __ ] up
art is so foreign to me though that like
who's the people looking at this and
going oh it's ruined it's not these
people now they have eyes though they
can look now i know right but then who
sees this and goes man it's so [ __ ]
dude what i can't believe this guy
[ __ ] this
how come you didn't draw eyes on the
middle head that's the art dude
come on you made that decision as an
artist you're right
it was the end of his shift he's not
gonna go home
he went to the end of a ship to draw the
island
this is actually pretty cool
it's quite relaxing [ __ ] [ __ ] it
don't work no more
this is a russian pain
tomorrow i'm coming for you
you're next
but this also proves that dudes up until
old age love to [ __ ] around
60 years old that's a really good case
study what do you think after his face
like i did good work today like you know
time to go home
two out of three not bad
[Music]
you